- [Announcer] This video is
brought to you by Fabulous.
(upbeat music)
- What's up, everybody?
Michael here and today I'm
gonna complain about taxi rides.
I've always thought New York is a place
where it's easy to get a taxi,
but it's not.
Taxis were not driving by,
so I, you know, went on the apps,
I was looking at Lyft and Uber
and things were 15 minutes away
and it cost, I'm not exaggerating,
like $50 to get a couple miles,
and it sucked and I wondered,
what's the point of
having all of these apps
if they don't do anything, right?
This is not the Uber that I used to know
nor the one that inspired
hundreds of businesses
billing themselves as Uber for laundry,
Uber for restaurants, Uber for toilets.
These companies, of course,
make up the gig economy
and they use slick intuitive apps
to organize contract workers
who can make all your
dreams come true for cheap.
Yet those promises have
become more suspect
as consumers face longer wait times
and higher costs for services.
This all has us wondering,
was the gig economy a farce built
on an unsustainable financial model?
Why are some of the most
successful gig startups struggling?
How has it become such a
dominant force in American labor
even as its flagship
companies continue to tank?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack Edition
on "The Gig Economy: What Went Wrong?"
But before we get into it,
I wanna tell you about this
video's sponsor, Fabulous.
The number one self-care app
to help build better habits
and achieve your goals.
If you find it tough to
stick to new routines
or if you're hoping to improve
your day-to-day happiness,
Fabulous is here to help.
It's a digital coach that
uses behavioral science
to help you create new
habits and stick to them.
Fabulous creates a
personalized daily routine
that can help you get on track
to achieve goals of any size,
whether it's to increase your
productivity, decrease stress,
or even, a thing that's important
to me, drink more water.
The app helps you create
rituals throughout the day,
starting from the moment you wake up.
These small steps help
you ease into new habits
and can lead to long-lasting changes.
You can choose between
two programs on Fabulous,
habit tracking or dedicated programs.
With the habit tracking approach,
you can go at your own pace
as you complete bite-sized tasks
and get gentle encouragement
throughout the day.
You can pick from 100 tasks
within the app or add your own.
With the dedicated programs,
you're immersed in a multi-week journey
of guided self-discovery.
Fabulous will send you inspiring
and motivational letters
and at the end of each one
you'll choose a positive action
for that week.
These new positive actions are
added to your daily routine
and the app sends friendly reminders
to help you stick to them.
And with the Fabulous premium account
you can track an
unlimited number of habits
and access all the programs and exercises
the app has to offer,
like coaching sessions
and support circles.
So join the community of
more than 30 million users
around the world
and start building your
ideal daily routine.
The first 100 people who click on the link
in the description
will get 25% off their
Fabulous subscription.
And now back to the show.
Now my little ride share
anecdote, as you know,
is become the norm.
As Derek Thompson's recent
piece in The Atlantic put it,
"Something beyond rising
energy and labor costs
is leading to sticker shock on
once-cheap urban amenities."
Clearly something has changed
since Airbnb first hit the scene in 2008.
This was the perfect
moment for the gig economy
to make its grand debut,
as the US was reeling
from the Great Recession.
The unemployment rate had doubled
and other workers faced
furloughs and reduced hours.
This made alternatives
to classic employment
seem quiet appealing,
like a potential safety net.
As economist Juliet Schor
writes in "After the Gig,"
in the years following 2008
people came to believe
that digital technology
could solve the problem of work.
The thinking went that
algorithms and crowdsourcing
could do the work of bosses
while software could
reorganize economic activity
into a person-to-person structure.
In this way she notes that
"this empowers individuals
to take control of their lives.
Vast swathes of the economy,
especially in services,
are ripe for this transformation.
This vision came to be
called the sharing economy."
Note that we're gonna
focus on the United States
and we're going by scholar Luigi Zingales'
definition of the gig economy
as any time you have "a digital platform
that coordinates a large
amount of people doing a job.
It's the case of Uber,
it's the case of Lyft,
it's the case of Airbnb,
it's the case of Fiverr,
it's the case of the
Mechanical Turks on Amazon."
And this model changed the very
idea of what labor could be.
It seemed to offer freedom and flexibility
without compromising wages via the magic
of part-time of gig-based work.
For folks without spare rooms to rent out,
Uber launched in 2009,
followed by Fiverr in 2010,
Rover in 2011,
Instacart in 2012 and beyond.
There was a gig for
seemingly every skill set.
Whether your specialty was
picking the ripest avocado,
bagging the (beep) of a stranger's dog,
or copy-editing somebody's novel.
Plus, you could hypothetically
make your own hours
and be your own boss
with your earning potential limited only
by your willingness to work hard.
This caught on fast.
By 2016, the Pew Research Center found
that nearly 25% of American adults
were making money from gig apps.
And the startup founders behind the apps
preached the gospel of
Silicon Valley utopianism,
promising staggering innovation.
Like Uber's grand plans
for self-driving cars
or Amazon delivering your
year supply of floss by drone,
it would be a brand new economy.
At first, it seemed to be working.
That is, if you didn't follow the money.
If you're paying $7 for that ride,
how is your Uber driver
making a living wage?
Well, A, they probably weren't,
and B, the baffling bankroll
was thanks to venture capitalists
who allowed gig economy
apps to operate at a loss.
This was based on the
assumption that in the future
when they've cornered the market
on, say, self-driving cars,
that's when they'll really see a profit.
In the meantime people got
used to the idea of $7 rides.
As Thompson writes,
"For the past decade, people like me,
youngish, urbanish, professionalish,
got a sweetheart deal from Uber,
the Uber-for-X clones
that vaguely pretended
to be tech companies.
Almost each time you or I ordered a pizza
or hailed a taxi,
the company behind that app lost money.
In effect, these startups,
backed by venture capital,
were paying us, the consumers,
to buy their products."
But are those glory days over
if consumers are no longer getting
too-good-to-be-true prices?
Because the gig economy has
always run on underpaid labor.
And to understand this
we need to contextualize where
gig as we know it came from.
As scholar Louis Hyman explains,
the decades following the New Deal
witnessed the golden age of
stable, long-term employment
when union membership was skyrocketing
and companies competing for top talent
started offering things
like generous wages
and employer-based healthcare.
But after the economic boom in the 1950s,
corporate structures started to change.
At the top, short-term consultants
started replacing executives,
while at the bottom union
workers were replaced
by cheaper day laborers.
And while these moves helped businesses
seem lean and therefore more profitable,
this also decreased job security.
This, as Hyman argues,
was indicative of a sea change
in how corporations function.
They went from primarily
trying to minimize risk
to primarily trying to maximize profits.
It wasn't about keeping
your family company running
and making quality goods for decades.
It was about making bank today.
And this was a whole new
way of looking at business.
The risk-taking entrepreneur
thus became the capitalist ideal.
And in pursuit of stand-alone
unabashed profits,
short-term returns became the new goal.
And one way to make
sure your quarterly ROI
looks shiny and efficient
is to hire flexible laborers
who take up less of your
operating cost overall.
The tech industry of the '70s and '80s
relied on this business model.
Short-term investments partnered
with flexible production
to great growth and success.
It also, as Hyman points out,
relied upon the use of undocumented labor
at an industrial scale
by the way of sub-contractors
who were paid on a per-project basis.
The rise of the internet
would greatly influence
how work is sourced and conducted,
making it even easier
to source temp workers
via Craigslist or apps.
No agency necessary.
These workers would be known
as independent contractors.
There are big benefits to
digitally sourcing contractors,
as Jamie Woodcock and Mark
Graham explain in their book
"The Gig Economy."
For one, it adds a layer of
invisibility and isolation
that obscures the people doing the work.
It's hard to know how
many colleagues you have
at TaskRabbit, after all,
if there is no way to
communicate with them.
And for many of these apps,
the sheer number of willing contractors
has created an over-supply of labor.
Woodcock and Graham write,
"As a result of this oversupply,
individual workers have very little power
to negotiate wages or working conditions."
Which is why workers way back when
started forming unions to begin with.
But unionizing is virtually impossible
for today's gig workers
because to form an union
you have to be an employee,
and people who work for Uber,
Lyft, Grubhub, Airbnb, and so on
are not actually employees.
This may sound like a technicality
but it's essential to the
way these companies function.
Unsurprisingly, when faced with a 2020
California ballot initiative, Prop 22,
which would exempt companies like Uber
from a state law that would
have required these companies
to treat workers like formal employees,
DoorDash, Lyft, Uber,
Instacart, and Postmates
spent $204 million on a
publicity campaign supporting it.
See, if somebody is your employee,
you're obligated to provide
things like overtime,
bargaining rights and healthcare.
According to The Seattle Times,
classifying your workforce
as independent contractors instead
can save companies 30%
or more on labor costs.
And for companies that were definitely
not all making a profit,
this would have made
their tenuous situations
even more slippery.
In the end, nearly 60% of voters agreed
that all the bells and
whistles of formal employment
were unnecessary, especially
if you jacked up prices
on services they had come to rely on.
The sheer amount of money
poured into this campaign
made Prop 22 the most
expensive ballot initiative
in US history,
and arguably it paid off.
Except not for workers, though.
Definitely didn't pay off for them.
In this way, we can see the gig economy
as being emblematic of a bigger shift
in the power of labor.
As sociologist Alexandrea
Ravanelle concluded,
"For all its app-enabled modernity,
the gig economy resembles
the early Industrial Age.
The sharing economy is
truly a movement forward
to the past."
That is a past before workers
had all the protections
they gained through
striking and organizing
since the 19th century
and through the protections
of the New Deal.
Now those prospects are unattractive
to the DoorDashers earning
an average of $1.45 an hour
for their labor, not counting tips,
according to Seattle-based
advocacy group PayUp.
But it is hugely attractive
to businesses and investors.
After all, when you classify
workers as contractors,
you take a lot less liability.
Laws governing actual
employment require companies
to implement worker and
consumer safety protections.
Under the gig economy,
all that risk is transferred
onto the workers themselves.
All this while many gig workers
aren't seeing the
flexibility-to-income ratio
they were promised.
They're urged on by apps
that penalize workers
who don't work enough,
like with TaskRabbit's 75%
recommended acceptance rate,
which impacts the number of
jobs available to workers
as well as the rate.
As Cherri Murphy,
a Bay Area-based ride
share driver explains,
working for Lyft provided
only so-called flexibility
and not her fellow drivers,
many of whom also happen
to be people of color,
were working 70 hours a week
and still living at or
below the poverty line.
As Murphy said,
"Over the years I found myself
in a deadly and inflexible cycle,
entrapped in working just
to afford to keep working."
Ultimately, these gig workers were trapped
in a big race to the bottom
plagued by unreliable pay,
alienating working conditions,
and a profound lack of
institutional support
from the mega-corporations they work for
but are not employed by.
But despite our gripes with
Uber and co's business models,
we still haven't answered the question,
why are they struggling?
We think it's pretty simple,
and it goes deeper than the pandemic
messed with the economy.
From the start, these
apps have been indicative
of an economic logic that
is fundamentally flawed,
and that's because it's
based on speculation
about future profitability.
It's a house built on a foundation of sand
which was conveniently
delivered by TaskRabbit.
Gig startups have mixed
material goods and services
carried out by real human beings
wit algorithm-based apps
which work on a logic
of inhuman efficiency.
Just as the 2008 financial
collapse revealed
that the real estate investment market
was built upon shaky investments
and repackaged high-risk loans,
the snowballing collapse
of the Uber-for-brushing-your-teeth
industry
shows that the future of profitability
that everyone imagined,
from founders to investors
to workers to consumers,
was exactly that, always rife
with internal contradiction.
But these companies were
able to speculate so wildly
because they had billions
of dollars of backing
from venture capitalists.
It still saved an enormous amount of loss
by treating its employees like
interchangeable contractors
rather than actually investing
in a stable workforce.
What's more, when businesses like Uber
openly and proudly declare
that they're here specifically
to disrupt an industry,
those disruptions can be seismic.
Many traditional jobs,
like taxi drivers or hotel concierges,
have been decimated if
not essentially eradicated
in a short span of time.
Most tragically, this has
resulted in a spike in suicide
amongst New York City taxi drivers
who, after investing huge sums of money
to get their medallions
and huge amounts of time in training,
saw their livelihoods destroyed.
Meanwhile, restaurants
adapting to delivery apps
have seen as much as 33%
commission off of order total.
So rather than revolutionizing
the modern economy,
these apps have actually
left it in worse shape
than they found it,
and that affects all of us.
As Hyman writes,
"When our corporations
fail, it hurts us all.
Yet when they succeed,
we do not get compensated for our risks.
American corporations,
as it is often said,
socialize risk and privatize return."
And the architects of these apps
appear to be getting off
as easily as bankers did
after the 2008 financial collapse.
At the same time, for millions of workers,
protections it took decades of agitation
by labor unions to be realized
have been stripped away.
This whole era calls to mind
something else that happened
in the mid 20th century.
The Taft-Hartley Act of 1947,
which burst in Kool-Aid Man style
to tamper union practices
most crucially with the introduction
of right to work laws,
which still exist.
And sure, right to work laws prohibit
mandatory joining of unions
for both private and public sector jobs,
arguably undermining hard-won solidarity.
As former union buster Martin
Jay Leavitt wrote in 1993,
Taft-Hartley Act meant "the
bosses could once again
wage their war with near impunity."
And at this point, about 14% of US workers
had already participated
in post-war strikes,
so bosses were particularly invested
in shutting that shit down.
The passing of Taft-Hartley
effectively defanged
organized labor's power,
preventing unions from putting
certain kinds of pressures on employers.
And the mainstreaming of contractor status
in the gig economy
could be seen as yet another attempt
to systematically roll
back worker protections
and further stymie organized labor.
And it's one that, if it
continues to be successful,
could have implications on your work life
regardless of if you've
ever done gig labor
because this model seems ripe to expand
even as the companies that
pioneered it are struggling.
A recent Mercer study shows
that 60% of (mumbles) executives
anticipate they will substantially replace
full-time employees with contract workers
within the next three years.
That is to say gig labor may
be coming for a lot of us.
That would lead many more folks doing
what Woodcock and Graham
call precarious work,
i.e. work that comes with "uncertainty
as to the duration of employment,
a lack of access to social
protection and benefits
usually associated with employment,
low pay and substantial
legal and practical obstacles
to joining a trade union and
bargaining collectively."
Workers doing this labor
make up what some call
the precariat class.
But as scholar Kathleen Thelen points out,
"Precarity is not the same as poverty
and it does not only
hit low skill workers.
It also affects highly skilled groups,
including professionals such
as airline pilots and lawyers
who are also employed increasingly
on flexible contracts."
And hell, there's even a trend
toward hiring CEOs on short-term basis
to help companies deal
with sudden departures
or navigate scandals.
It seems that truly no one is safe
from the oncoming shift into
the wild world of gig labor.
From companies hiring
two part-time employees
instead of one full-timer,
to outsourcing HR work
to contractors or apps,
we're increasingly being
taught to expect less and less
from our employers.
And they're increasingly aware
of what they can get away with.
As former CEO of Gigwalk
Bob Bahramipour put it,
"You can hire 10,000 people
for 10 to 15 minutes.
When they're done, those
10,000 people just melt away."
So are we all fated for a
Frosty the Snowman-style demise?
Because despite all his criticisms,
Hyman still believes in
some of the early promises
of the gig economy.
He just thinks this version of it
was deliberately constructed
to only benefit those at the top.
But for regular folks
who are still craving
the freedom of gig work,
is there a way to make it
actually work for everyone?
The way Hyman sees it, maybe.
He argues that the idea
of decentralization
that underpins the gig or sharing economy
could usher us into what he calls
a post-corporate capitalism.
Worker-owned co-ops could create
a more dominant peer-to-peer economy
where apps are owned collectively
so as to allow workers
to control the fruits
of their own labor.
Or as economist David Korten put it,
"Post-corporate capitalism
opens up the possibility for us
to treat money as the facilitator,
not the purpose of our economic lives."
And we're already starting to see examples
of this new approach in real life.
The Co-Op Ride app, for instance,
is the largest worker-owned
cooperative in America
and its members earn up to 10% more
than when driving for Uber or Lyft.
After all, if the gig economy
has weakened traditional corporations
and opened up our perceptions
of what jobs can be,
what could that mean for
our relationship to work?
Is there any way we can get a do-over
on the promise of the gig economy?
Hyman writes, "Technology
creates new possibilities,
but only we determine our future,
or at least we have every
time before in human history.
The wage connected to a job
might be a passing moment
in our economic past,
a footnote to history."
Some thinkers have
envisioned a gig economy
based on what they call portable benefits.
That is a system where the healthcare
and paid leave and other
things afforded to employees
could follow you from
TaskRabbitting Ikea furniture
to bagging a frat house's
booze supply for Drizly.
But will this starry-eyed
vision ever manifest?
All signs are currently
pointing to probably not.
But at least according to some theorists,
there is still potential
to use these technologies
to fundamentally rethink
what labor looks like
in the first place.
So what we're saying is
weirder things have happened.
But what do you all think?
Can the gig economy be transformed,
or are we all just gonna
get app-ed to death?
Let us know in the comments.
And thanks as always to our
patrons for your support
and don't forget to check out
all of our update Patreon perks.
And check out our WiseCrack
livestream right here
Thursdays at 11:00 a.m. Pacific.
Remember to like this video, subscribe,
and hell, maybe even ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)